(dramatic music)
- Welcome to A Conversation with History.
I'm Harry Kreisler
of the Institute of International Studies.
Our guest today is Martha C. Nussbaum,
who is a philosopher and Ernst Freund
Distinguished Service
Professor of Law and Ethics
at the University of Chicago.
She is on the Berkeley campus to deliver
the 2006-07 Forester Lectures.
Professor Nussbaum has made
significant contributions
to an array of disciplines,
working within the fields
of philosophy, law,
classics, and political science.
She has advanced the
inter-disciplinary study
of ongoing problems in areas
such as cognition and emotions,
feminism, democracy, religion,
and education, among others.
Some of her publications
include "Upheavals of Thought:
"The Intelligence of Emotions",
"Cultivating Humanity: A Classical Defense
"of Reform of Liberal Education",
"The Fragility of
Goodness: Luck and Ethics
"in Greek Tragedy and Philosophy",
and "Women and Human Development:
"The Capabilities Approach".
Professor Nussbaum, welcome to Berkeley.
- Thanks very much, Harry,
it's really great to be here.
- Where were you born and raised?
- Well I was born in New York
City, but then soon after that
we moved to suburban Philadelphia,
so I grew up on what
was called the Main Line
in Bryn Mawr, Pennsylvania.
- And looking back, how
do you think your parents
shaped your thinking about the world?
- Well, you know, I didn't
really like Bryn Mawr.
I thought it was elitist and snobbish,
and so I got an interest
in breaking out of that
and looking at the wider world
and thinking about inequalities
of race and class and so on.
But also, in a more positive way,
my father was a very
determined, hard-working person
who had actually brought
his way up from poverty
to be a partner in a big law firm,
and he was a tremendous influence,
'cause he loved to work
hard and he thought
you should get the maximum
out of whatever abilities
you had, and so he just taught me,
never let down, and
just always get the most
out of whatever you're doing.
- [Harry] And your mother?
- My mother was a very unhappy woman.
She had given up a career
as an interior decorator,
and she was very bored and unhappy.
She was a very loving woman, and I feel
that she was a great
source of love and emotion.
In fact, once I wrote a
philosophical dialogue
that my parents figure
in, and she's the one
who speaks for the emotions.
But I also learned that
women who are forced
to give up their careers
don't always have happy lives,
and that was important to me.
- Before you take off to
college, what in your training,
your education, made you
think that you might wanna
be a philosopher, or did
that only come later?
- I went to this very
intense feminist school
where we thought a lot about ideas,
and I had great, great teachers.
I didn't call it philosophy at the time.
I thought about literature,
but I wrote about Dostoevsky,
I wrote about Shakespeare,
and I was thinking about
a lot of the same issues
that I think about now, about
emotions and vulnerability.
I was also reading Greek tragedies,
so you know, it was very continuous with
what I'm doing now, but I just didn't hear
the word philosophy very much.
And, actually, not for a long time,
because, you know, I first
went to graduate school
in classical literature,
and I switched to philosophy
only during graduate school.
- And were you a debater,
just out of curiosity,
as a young person?
- No, I was an actress.
- An actress?
- I did a lot of acting and I wanted
to be a professional
actress and I actually was
in two summers and then one whole year,
I did professional
repertory theater acting,
and it was only when I realized
that I really wanted to
think about the plays
and not to act in them that
I went back to regular school
and finished undergraduate school,
but I got a lot out of
that, and I still enjoy
performing my own scripts,
but as a lecturer,
you can write the script yourself.
- And the,
your admirable style as a lecturer
really comes out,
and this maybe points
us into an understanding
of how that came about.
- Well, and you know, in
teaching, I always try
very hard to dramatize
the philosophical issue,
make it seem like a real human problem
that people are actually worried about,
because I think philosophy can seem
to undergraduates very dry.
But it isn't, it's the
most urgent questions
about human life, and so I
feel some dramatic ability
helps when you try to bring that out.
- And so as an undergraduate,
you majored in theater
arts and then literature?
Is that what was your path here?
- Well, you know, I was
in the School of the Arts
for one year at NYU.
- At NYU.
- Yeah, and then when I
went back to regular school.
And so, I mean I'd left
Wellesley for this acting job.
I went to NYU School of the Arts.
Then I just went back and I
majored in classics, actually,
and then I went on to
graduate school at Harvard
in classics, but very quickly got into
the philosophical side of it.
Because that was where the excitement was
right then at Harvard.
- And was that because of the instruction
you were getting, or it
was just what drew you,
what really attracted you?
- Well, you know the people
who were teaching tragedy
were not really
intellectually challenging.
And they weren't interested
in the ideas in it,
and G.E.L. Owen, this great scholar
who worked on Plato and Aristotle,
he was challenging and exciting,
and so it was the whole circle around Owen
that was very rigorous, very challenging.
And so I got into that circle,
but I still felt that there was something,
talking about emotions,
talking about ethical issues,
that was missing there.
And when Bernard Williams came to Harvard
to teach for a year,
then I saw that that's
possible to do that within philosophy.
And that's what I really wanted to do.
I mean, what I wanted
to do was not to talk
about these things in the way
that a classical scholar did,
just editing the text or
whatever was being done
at the time, I wanted to talk
about the philosophical issues,
about moral dilemmas, about
the emotions and so on.
So Williams gave me a
tremendous sense of possibility
and permission in the sense
that if he could do that
within philosophy, then it
could be done within philosophy.
At the time, it was tough,
because people, if you
talked about emotions,
or even about friendship,
especially if you were a woman,
they thought, "Oh, you softie,
"you're not really a philosopher."
But Williams was an iconoclast,
and because he was so respected,
he gave other people permission
to follow and do that.
- So this would've been in the 70s,
so it was an ideal time
for a woman to be entering
philosophy and raising these issues.
Is that a fair statement,
or was it still a struggle?
- Well, it was a struggle.
I actually have written
a piece for a volume
of memoirs of women in philosophy.
I think there were a lot of problems
about sexual harassment, and
I certainly encountered that.
There were a lot of
problems about child care.
I had a child when I was only 25,
when I was in my third
year of graduate school.
No one knew what to do about that.
All the department colloquia were held
at just the hour when the
child care centers closed
and no one understood
that, so I felt that I was
the first one kind of blazing
the trail for these issues,
and it was very, very tough.
I was tired a lot of the time,
and I did encounter a tremendous
amount of discrimination.
But probably less than
other women at other places,
because I think that some
of the people at Harvard,
like Hilary Putnam, John Rawls,
were extremely fair-minded
and great voices for women.
So was Bernard Williams,
long before there was
the term sexual harassment, he
was telling women to protest
when men on the faculty harassed them.
- Our program goes out
to a general audience,
and I wonder if I could ask you kind of
a naive question here, which
is what does a philosopher do?
Help us understand what that's all about.
- Well, you know, I think
philosophy has only some unity.
I mean, philosophers do
many, many different things,
but if I just stick with moral
and political philosophy,
I think that there are
some very general questions
about the basis of the moral life
where laying it out in a reasoned way
can actually help us.
It starts from Socrates.
Socrates thought that
if you didn't examine
your ethical beliefs, then
you probably were just a mess.
I mean, you were
inconsistent and that meant
you could be self-serving.
You could do what you felt like
and rationalize it some way.
But if you really examined your beliefs,
then you had to put
yourself on a short leash.
And if you said that you were all for X,
well, you had to do that consistently.
And so I think, you
know, in our moral lives,
one of the great problems is this kind of
self-serving partiality, where we think,
"Oh, well, yes, of course that's a rule,
"but it applies to other
people and not to me."
Or we don't even think that far.
So, philosophizing gives you a set of,
as it were, guidelines and guardrails.
It won't be any good if you don't start
with basically healthy
ethical convictions.
I don't think philosophy can
conduct a radical reform.
So that's why I think the
feminist movement didn't,
couldn't have much role for philosophy
until it had already
progressed a certain distance
through a kind of radical evangelizing
and consciousness-raising,
but then once that happens,
it's good to lay it out
more systematically,
and say, "Where are we now,
"and how can we actually be
fully fair and inclusive,
"and get the best out of our convictions?"
So I think what a philosopher does is just
try to think through the convictions
and think through in a more
rigorous and systematic way,
which sometimes can
involve quite elaborate
and formal kinds of
reasoning, but not always.
And then often what that shows you is that
a certain area that is
calling out for attention
has not actually been well addressed.
And so I think you always
have to be responsive also
to the world and the new problems in it.
I mean, I've just now been
writing about global justice,
and I think that theories of justice,
up until recently, did
okay when they're talking
about a single nation, but
they didn't really think
very well about the larger
world and the different kinds
of institutions that are in it,
the role of multinational corporations,
the role of international agencies.
So you have to know something
about the world also
and care about that.
- What, you said you've
covered so many important areas
in your work, which we can't
all cover in this hour,
but I'm curious what, help us understand
the synergies involved in
your picking your agenda
at particular times.
Is it events in the world,
is it your background,
is it your readings,
is there something that
you can tell us about that?
- Well, I think if the
work is going to be good,
it has to come from someplace deep in you,
and in my case, I think the driving issue
is human vulnerability
and trying to understand
what that means for the conduct of life.
The fact that we are such
that we can be robbed
of the things we love most in an instant,
and that if we're gonna plan for a life,
we just don't know whether
that plan can be carried out.
I mean, that plan has
preoccupied philosophers
over the ages, and not surprisingly.
But it's what got me going,
and I wanted to think
about the emotions,
because I think of them
as our ways of registering how things are
with our uncertain projects
out there in the world,
our attachments to people
beyond our control.
But then, also, that led
me to political philosophy,
because, all right, here are people
who are more vulnerable
than they should be
because they don't have enough food,
they don't have enough health care,
and surely, one of the main
jobs of political arrangements
is to bring the things
people need more securely
within their control.
And of course, you don't want a life
in which you control everything,
because that would be
a life without love and a
life without friendship.
But a life in which you
have enough to eat, drink,
and which certain central
goods are securely guaranteed
to you by the society that you live in,
that I think is a reasonable expectation.
Now, I got to that in my mind,
but I was also catapulted
into it by events,
because I came with the
economist Amartya Sen.
I think you've interviewed him,
and he won the Nobel Prize in 1998.
I came to co-author a paper
with him to a U.N. institute
in Helsinki, which was the World Institute
for Development Economics Research,
and then I saw how
fascinating and how urgent
and compelling the problems
of developing countries were,
particularly problems of
women and their inequalities,
and I just became a research
advisor at that institute,
and I stayed there, talking to people
from lots of different
countries, and for 10 years,
I did that kind of work
one month every year
to learn about the world.
So that kind of immersion in
an international institute
was very, very crucial for me.
- Let me show this book.
It's one of the many that you've written,
but we will be talking about it,
and you just touched on it,
"Women and Human Development:
The Capabilities Approach".
And it probably is a good focal point
as our discussion proceeds.
This book drew you in
in a way, metaphorically,
I guess I could say, it drew
you away from the library
because you really had
to go into the field
and encounter
the lives of women as you went to India
on several trips and traveled there
and lived there and so on.
Talk a little about that,
because one of the points
that you're making is that
experience of women's rights
and being denied rights
that you experienced,
we just talked about, in graduate school
was very different when you come to
a developing place like India.
- Yeah, well, I saw
already at the institute
that I was very ignorant.
That my education had been very bad,
because it was only a Western education.
And so I started trying
to learn about conditions
in other countries, and I went to India.
But when I was going to write this book,
I thought, well, I don't
wanna pull in one example
from China and one example
from Iran, and so on,
but I wanna get to know
one country pretty well,
because I think that
only when you understand
these issues that people are fighting for
in their historical and regional context
can you say anything reasonable.
Well, I already loved India,
and I've been more and more
drawn into India all the time,
so I said to an activist friend of mine,
"Please help me", I
mean she works in India,
"Please help me learn.
"And just set me up with an
itinerary where I can go around
"and meet with women's
groups all over the country
"and see what women are
really fighting for."
And what I found was that, of course,
the issues are continuous with issues
that feminists talk about in the US,
sexual harassment, domestic violence,
adequate rape law, these are big issues.
But they're also quite other issues
that we don't think so
much about because maybe
we take them for granted,
like girls being able to go to school,
girls being able not to be married at six,
girls being able to have some access
to employment opportunities,
being able to have equal property rights.
And so these things are very
connected with the others.
Because in fact, one main way that women
can stand up to their husbands
against domestic violence
is by having a job so
that the husband knows
that they can exit if they want to.
They can take that money
out of the household.
And also by having land, you know,
if they have land, then
he knows, "She can go
"and then I'm losing."
So to think about the
interconnections of all those issues
was very, very important, because I think
you just can't even have
an adequate proposal
in one of these areas unless
you see the whole layout
and how the problems mesh together.
Also to see a different political culture,
because I think we think,
a lot of Americans think,
"Oh, thriving Western democracies."
But actually, to me, India is
a much more thriving democracy
because there's a great
deal more voter turnout.
The rural poor are very
invested in politics.
Gandhi set up rural village councils
that bring people in to
the political process
even if they can't read and write.
They get very involved
in shaping the nation,
and often decide the results of elections.
So I like the Indian democracy.
I like people's passion for justice.
When I would go to the
poorest places, you know,
women were not just moaning and groaning,
they were really making plans,
they were excited about
what they were doing,
and they would often sing
songs and use the arts
to dramatize their optimism.
- And so how did this
experience in this thinking,
in what way did it lead to a formulation
and what is that formulation that you,
you emphasize capabilities?
- Yes, okay, let me tell
you what that idea means.
And it's actually
something that Sen had been
working on already
before, and I developed it
in a more philosophical way,
but the international agencies,
when they looked at
countries in the old days,
they used to ask just one question,
that is, how is the economy doing?
How much growth is there?
And they would measure that by looking at
the gross national product per capita.
Well, you can see that
if you're really trying
to find out how people are doing,
and what their quality of life is,
that's very crude, because
it doesn't even look
at distribution, and
it would typically give
very high marks to
nations like South Africa
under apartheid that
had huge inequalities.
It also doesn't identify and separate
the different aspects of the human life;
Health, education, bodily integrity,
all these things are separate,
and you might have a nation, for example,
the United States, that does pretty well
on some of these indicators,
but does very badly on domestic violence.
So you wanna look at each
one of these separately.
And so the idea of capabilities is
that you ask the question, what are people
actually able to do and to be?
And then what I've done
that Sen doesn't do
is I specify 10 central things
that I think are central indicators
that any decent society
would make quite pivotal,
and would guarantee to all citizens
up to an adequate threshold level.
So I look at life,
health, bodily integrity,
development of senses,
imagination, and thought
through education, practical
reason, affiliation,
access to recreation and play,
because I think that's
too little talked about.
But women who have to do all the housework
and all the, and have an outside job, too,
one of the things they
often lack is recreation.
I talk about control over
material and social environment,
and also about access
to a good relationship
with nature and the environment.
So those are the ones that I focus on,
and then emotional health is the last one
that I've added because I
think that that's, again,
that's something that
women, even women who seem
to be doing well and they've
got enough money and so on,
they're often living with a lot of fear
and a lot of anger that's perhaps produced
by the inequalities and
pressures upon them.
So that, too, seems to me to
be an important indicator.
And then, what I think is,
you have to find some way of,
of course, measuring these,
and that's the challenge for partnership
between philosophers and economists,
but that it puts the
question in the right place.
It really is looking at the
thing you need to look at.
The human development
reports of the United Nations
Development Program have been
measuring quality of life
in countries by looking at
capabilities since 1990,
and it's made a difference to
the way politicians do things.
They care now much more about
education and health care,
because they see that they're
separate from economic growth.
Just raising economic
indicators does not deliver
a more adequate level of
health care and education.
So, it's an approach that's having
some real practical impact
and the intellectual work
has to keep being developed further,
and keep being pushed further,
but now we have an
international association
called the Human Development
and Capability Association
that has 700 members
from about 40 countries.
And to me, it's thrilling
to see young people come in
and contest my formulations, mix it up,
have a good argument, and then also,
think about ways to translate
this into actual policy.
So it's a movement now.
- Was this experience
unusual in the context
of your other work in the
sense that you're really
going out into the field
and, I guess, one would say
doing empirical research about the ideas
that you were developing?
Was this a unique
experience in that sense,
or do you do it more often
than not in your other works?
- Well, you know, I think
any real empirical research
requires partnership with
people who know how to do that,
and what I did when I
went out into the field
was just educate myself to
raise the right questions,
but if I really want to
know what correlations
are there between, let's say, land rights
and domestic violence, I'll ask somebody
who does empirical research.
And I've made a network of partners
and I can consult them and
that's one of the things
our association is about too.
But I guess, I think,
that's something I do also
when I write about the emotions.
That I'm very interested in
what experimental psychology
tells us about emotions.
I'm very interested in
what biology tells us.
What I contribute is something different.
In both cases, what I'm
mainly contributing, I think,
is a kind of thinking through,
laying out systematically,
offering the justifications, and so on.
But, no good unless you
have adequate contact
with the empirical stuff.
- In your work in India,
you come up against
the importance of religion
as a defining feature
of the environment that makes
implementation of some goals,
if not impossible, then difficult.
Talk about that, the
insights you developed
about religion and the way one had
to really lay out the conflict
between religious rights
and this new agenda of women's rights.
- Yeah, well, of course,
I think it's obvious
that traditional
religions have given women
a second-class status in
pretty much every case,
and it's only very recently that you have
reform movements within all
the major religions, really,
that are trying to give
women a more equal status.
Now, I guess it's a cliche of feminism
that religion is, per se, bad for women.
I don't actually believe that.
I think that women, you know,
as religion was a source
for social justice in our
civil rights movement,
I think it can also be a
source of energy for feminists,
and it has been, but I think
religion is a part of culture,
and all traditional
cultures have been sexist,
and so all traditional
religions have been sexist.
So I think what one has to ask is
how far do we make concessions to people
who maintain sexist practices just because
they cite a religious basis?
So that was a question
that I pose in the book.
Now, I think there are two extremes
that you could go to.
One extreme would be to say, well,
we don't pay any attention to
the fact that it's religion.
It doesn't make any
difference to us at all.
I think that's wrong because I think
that very often, our knowledge
of religious persecution
is such that we see that people very often
are too inattentive to religious claims
and even when things are not,
mistakes don't seem to
be high for public order
and other people's rights.
So for example, work days,
people will work on Saturday,
but they won't work on Sunday.
And if somebody has a religious reason
for not working on Saturday,
they often have great difficulty
maintaining a job, getting
unemployment compensation
and so on.
So I think in those cases,
the religious reason should
be taken very seriously.
I also think when somebody
doesn't want to do
military service because
a of religions reason,
that should be taken seriously.
I think these claims are often very deep
in people's lives and they
should be listened to.
In India, for example, the
drug laws are routinely
suspended for the
religious holiday of Holi
because you are supposed to use marijuana
and hashish on Holi.
And it's easy to do that because Hinduism
is the majority religion.
But if it was some minority,
like the Native Americans
have had this problem in the US,
well, you can bet people would say,
"Oh, drugs, this is really terrible."
So I think these religious claims,
wherever the rights of
others and public order
and safety are not at stake,
they should be taken very seriously.
So the other extreme however
is to say that religion
always trumps other concerns.
And so what I try to argue in the book
is that my capabilities list,
which is, I mean, what I say is that the,
a certain threshold level of these
10 capabilities on my list is essential
for a life with human dignity.
And if I've successfully argued that,
then we certainly don't
think it's a decent society
unless people are allowed
to have all of those
because it's been argued
that that's not a life
with human dignity.
Well, then I would say those 10,
if the argument has been well made,
trump religious reasons.
So for example, any
practice of child marriage
which is a great offense
to women's education,
to their bodily integrity and so on
would be ruled out by
that kind of principle.
On the other hand, the woman
chooses to wear a veil.
Well, then the issue of
choice becomes very complex
and we have to start having
to ask about parents' rights
over their children, but up to a point,
I think that one can defend that practice
so long as there's sufficient
guarantees of education,
employment options, property rights,
and exit options from that religion.
So those are, I think, are the
things that make it a choice
if a woman is going to
have a life of veiling.
And so this is the way I think about it,
that you just look at the
overall menu of the opportunities
that the woman has, and if she really has
the 10 capabilities on my list,
and then she leads a
life that we don't like
because we think it's too authoritarian,
she submits herself to an
authoritarian religion,
an authoritarian relationship.
Well, if she really,
if the political situation
that she lives in
has really provided her
with those 10 capabilities,
which would include primary
and secondary education,
political rights and liberties
and health care and so on,
then I think that's her choice.
And of course, some
people do choose to serve
in an authoritarian
group like the military,
and we don't think that
the people who choose to be
career military people
are always not choosing,
although of course, they are too.
There's an issue of economic constraint,
and if they're constrained into that life
because they don't have any
other options, that's bad,
but if they choose that
life, then that's not so bad.
So that's the way I think about it
and I think what I see in India is that
that's basically what the
women's movement is working for.
They do not want to portray
themselves as hostile
to Hinduism, or in the
case of Islam, to Islam,
but in fact, women are
working within these religions
to achieve changes.
Hindu women in India this
year just succeeded in
reforming the unequal property law
so that women have equal
shares in agricultural land,
which was a big deal.
And it really is highly correlated
with other rights and opportunities.
So, those are the sorts of
things that they're working for,
but they don't say, "We
have to junk Hinduism",
they just reform the Hindu property law.
The difficulty doing
this is that actually,
male clerics play a big role in society,
as in every country.
And so for example,
Christian women in India
got the right to divorce
on the grounds of cruelty
only in the year 2001 because
the different kinds of Catholic priests
and Protestant ministers and so on,
they resisted change for many years.
And then when they decided
change might be good,
then they had to all get together
and agree on some formulation.
So the Protestants and the Catholics
and the ones from Portugal and the ones
originally from some other place,
they all had to get together
and it took a long time,
and it's ridiculous.
Actually, Christian rights of women
have been particularly
slow because they come from
so many different religions
and so many different origins.
Muslim women had that right earlier,
but the Muslim women
have a similar problem,
which is that there's a thing called
the Muslim Personal Law Board,
which is a bunch of unelected
self-perpetuating male clerics
who decide what the rules should be,
and because they're not accountable,
they don't really listen
enough to the voices of women.
So there are these
struggles in every religion,
and then of course after that,
they have to persuade Parliament
to pass the right, reform law,
and that takes another
five years, and so on.
So yeah, so there are these problems,
but I think one should not say,
and I don't see women saying
that we want to just
junk religion, per se.
- You're raising some interesting points
and there are two insights that I found
in your discussion of religion
that I think are useful
in other areas.
One is the role of power, which
you were just talking about.
But also the inability or
incapacity to see diversity
of thinking within a religion.
And the two of these together
can further the possibility of change,
which is really important
as we deal with religions
that we don't understand
in our involvement.
- Oh yeah, I mean, I think
when Americans look abroad,
they often, they talk about traditions
or the Indian tradition.
Now very often, it's absurd
because to even use the phrase
the Indian tradition makes no sense at all
because it's a, such a
heterogeneous country
with 350 languages and so many
different regional cultures
and so many different religions, I mean,
not just Hinduism, Islam and Christianity,
but also there are Parsees,
there are Jews there.
So just, Buddhists, Sikhs, Gaians.
So we then, within each
of these, have diversity.
And often, I think
people think it's a good
kind of pluralistic thing to do to say,
"Oh well, it's their tradition,
so we mustn't criticize it."
But often what that means is
you're just conceding that the voices
of the currently powerful men should rule
and you're not even listening
to the voices of women
who probably haven't
learned to read and write
and therefore they're not recorded
as part of the dominant tradition.
And interestingly, this
is what the British did
when they were ruling over India.
When native Indian reformers said,
"We don't want child marriage anymore",
the British judges said, "Oh,
but it's the Hindu tradition."
Now of course, they were
deferring to the powerful men
in the community.
Why were they doing that?
Because they had the shrewd idea
that if you give them that,
that control over women,
then they might be less antsy
about rebelling against the British.
So the man who can be a king in his house
is less likely to notice
that he's not a king
the rest of the world.
So the British played up
cultural relativism as a tool
of their own power,
and I think that's an
example we should think about
because I think Americans
sometimes make similar errors
just out of naivete.
They think, "Oh well, the
tradition of Hinduism is X,
"or the tradition of
Islam", but all of these
have had argument and debate for years.
I mean, Islamic feminism in
India has a very old history
and the wonderful works
and novels and so on
written by women, and so
too with Hindu feminism.
I find that some of,
do you know the recent
movie Water by Deepa Mehta?
- No.
- Well, it's a movie
made by a Canadian emigre
who had left India at the age of 20
and then she went to Canada,
and it portrays Hinduism
as monolithically terrible
in its attitude toward widows,
all widows have to go to this ashram
and live a miserable life,
and only Gandhi could save
them from this terrible life.
Now in fact, starting in
the 19th century already,
women themselves were taking the lead
in rebelling against
the treatment of widows.
There were conferences on widowhood,
there were women who set
up schools for widows.
So all of this is just left out,
so I think any account of a culture
really needs to begin by listening
to the voices of dissent within that
and just understanding that it's always
a scene of contestation.
What would you expect?
I mean, the family is always
a scene of contestation,
as we know very well.
Well, why should a
tradition be any different?
And it isn't, it never is.
- Now, as you're working
through these problems,
you actually put on your
hat as a legal philosopher.
And I want you to talk a
little about that because
you see the law and the principles
that have evolved over time
even from different settings
as something to think about
as one navigates the movement,
the aggressive movements of women's rights
as it comes up against the obstacles
that might be in a religion.
Talk a little about that,
'cause law is central, right?
- Well, feminism has always in America,
and in Europe I would say,
but especially I guess in the US,
it has relied on law as an
avenue of social change.
The first very famous legal
feminist was Catharine MacKinnon
but there were so many.
And these women thought,
"Well, what we really need,
"what we can make progress
with is better laws on rape,
"some laws on sexual harassment,
"understanding that sexual
harassment is not about
"being sexy but it's the
practice of discrimination
"and subordination", all these things
which were put gradually
into the law so that now,
the most conservative federal judge
is bound to recognize that
the asymmetry of power
in the workplace is an ingredient
of thinking about sexual harassment.
So I think that's something
that has really happened
a lot in the US, and I
think it's happened in part
because law is a very
high prestige profession,
people listen to what lawyers say,
and people have pretty, pretty good access
to the legal system.
I mean, it's not perfect,
we need better public defenders and so on,
but as the movie The Accused shows
where that woman who was
gang-raped got an adequate lawyer
through the public defender
system, that was a real case
and that really happened.
And when my law students see it,
they understand that there's something
that they're involved
in that is progressive
and that can really change the law.
That was the case that
established that no means no,
that if you're wearing sexy clothes
and you say no, that's no.
Now, I have to say that
it's not the same in India.
That is in India, people
think it's a little naive
and starry-eyed to think that a main way
of making change for women
is to work on law reform
in the way that I'm
used to doing in the US,
and that's partly because law
is not such a respected
profession nationwide
because legal change is very
slow and very cumbersome,
and because the access to the courts
is compromised by corruption.
A woman who registers a rape complaint,
that case will average take
nine years to get to court.
And so until you fix that, I mean,
there's no point in changing a law because
the most fundamental thing is
she needs to get on with her life,
and so she needs prompt adjudication.
So what I think is badly needed,
and so I've worked with a legal
non-governmental organization
in India that works
on feminist issues, they think too reform,
massive reform of legal education,
they would like to try to
start a private law school
because the state-run
ones are just very poor,
they don't teach feminist approaches,
they don't teach all this new stuff.
The judiciary is very good nonetheless,
so if you ever manage to
get up to the Supreme Court
and even the high courts of the states,
then that's okay, and this organization
that I've worked with has
a wonderful woman named
Indira Jaising who's
brought some extraordinary,
important cases on sexual
harassment before the court.
But it's the lower levels where
women are just floundering
and doing very badly.
So I think one first has
to have the rule of law
and a smooth, efficient legal system
before feminists can hope
that that's the way they'll change things.
- Does this problem of
the role of religion
and the role of the state,
their interactions and so on
is a problem that you
are grappling with now?
Is that correct?
And tell us a little about
that research of thinking about
what it is to have freedom of religion
and religious practice.
- This is a rare case
where I'm focusing on
the American tradition,
and I did it because,
after the election of 2004,
I felt I wanted to make an intervention
into the public debate because
I think that people are
increasingly polarized
around religious matters,
and they misunderstand
often certain things
about the tradition.
I think the religious people think
that the idea of separation
of church and state
is an idea that means that
religion is being marginalized,
it's being trivialized, it's
being said to be unimportant.
And so what I set out to show
is that there is a long tradition,
you could associate it
particularly with Madison,
although I think it goes back
further to the 17th century
and Roger Williams that
says no, the issue,
the central issue is one of fairness.
We want all to be
citizens of equal standing
in the public realm.
We want not just adequate
liberty, but equal liberty.
Now what that means is that any kind
of religious establishment
or religious orthodoxy
in public life is a problem
because it jeopardizes
that equal standing.
Madison was thinking
about a law in Virginia,
which seems very benign,
and it's what lots of
European countries have now
which is that there would be a tax
for the benefit of the Anglican Church,
but if you have some other church,
you could always choose to
give it instead to your church.
And he said, "No, by
making the Anglican Church
"the central one, this makes
a statement that that's,
"our society is basically
an Anglican society,
"and other people don't enter
the polity", as he put it,
"On equal conditions."
So that line has been very important
in the Supreme Court's
thinking about establishment
and why establishment is bad,
and I think that equality line
is really the one to press
when we think about why
school prayer might be bad.
It's not like we think,
"Oh, children are contaminated by prayer",
but it's just that any prayer you choose
is going to include
some and exclude others.
It's going to, and one
of the landmark cases was
a young boy in Pennsylvania
who decided on the day
of required Bible reading
that he was gonna bring in
a copy of the Quran, and
he read from the Quran.
Well, he got sent to
the principal's office
and his principal took half out after him,
wrote to every college
he had ever applied to
and got to admit this--
- This was a recent case?
- This was 1960s, Abington versus Schempp.
It was this kid Ellery Schempp
who's now a distinguished physicist,
and he's obviously a brilliant kid.
It's one of the rare cases
where the kid actually brought the case,
the parents were only
kind of helping him out,
but he sent $10 to the ACLU and he said,
"Will you take my case?"
And they did, and what emerged
from that was that of course
the public schools,
oh, and they thought that
they were being neutral,
but they were really Protestant schools.
They were choosing of
course the King James Bible,
not the Catholic Bible, and in his case,
just the Quran just
filled them with horror.
There were no Muslims,
he wasn't the Muslim,
he was just trying to make
a point about pluralism.
And so the point is that any
kind of religious observance
you choose is always
going to be somebody's
and not somebody else's,
and fair to some and excluding of others.
And I want people to think about
that and what that implies,
and if we want to separate
religion from the public realm,
it's not because we hate religion
or because we think that it
doesn't belong in human life,
it's because it just can't be done
in a way that's fair to all
and gives all equal liberty.
Now I think that also
means that we shouldn't
impose special burdens on religion.
I mean for example, suppose
we had a situation in which
the public sewer system
didn't serve the churches,
and the fire department
wouldn't come to put out a fire
in a church.
Now you might think
separation of church and state
requires that situation, right?
Because we want, the state
is the fire department,
and here's the church, well,
then they shouldn't be mixed.
But see, that's why I
think separation is not
a very helpful idea, but equality is
a much more helpful idea.
And well, what we can see is
it just would not be
fair to religious people
if they didn't get these
basic life protections
of the sewer system and
the fire department.
Now then, of course,
there's a lot of gray area
in the middle.
Do they get transportation
to parochial schools
on the public buses?
You know, all these
things are very contested,
but I think that when we think about them,
the right way of thinking about it is
we don't want to have a state that's,
that burdens religion in a way
that the non-religious are not burdened.
We also don't want to have
a state that favors religion
or any particular religion.
So that's the line and I mean,
it's the line that the court,
the mainstream, the kind of
center of the Supreme Court
has been pushing for a long time,
but these things have change
and I think right now,
it is in jeopardy.
And so I think it's a time to reaffirm
the tremendous importance
of that equal status idea.
- Your career, just the little
bits that we've talked about
really strike me as
offering us a lot of thought
about how students might
train for the future.
The kinds of curriculum,
the kinds of worldviews
that they should have.
I know you've worked a lot on this.
I actually have that one, that book here,
"Cultivating Humanity: A Classical Defense
"of Reform and Liberal Education".
Talk a little about that.
I mean we, in the brief time we have,
we can't cover what all it covered,
but what are the central
features do you think
of an adequate preparation
for a future that
reflects both this, insights
that you've offered us about
those things that emerge out
of the American tradition,
but also sensitive to
the very great diversity
out there in the world.
- Yeah, well, this is a book about
higher education in America,
and it's about the liberal
education part of it,
which is something that we're,
I think we're lucky to have that
because most nations don't have that
in their university system.
They just go in and they study one thing,
but we have an opportunity,
we're at an age where young people
are already pretty independent
and pretty sophisticated
to give them a general preparation
for citizenship and life.
So my question was focusing now
on the role of the humanities
and the social sciences
because I think other people
can talk better than I can
about the science part.
What should that involve?
And I argue that there are
three abilities above all
that we need to cultivate
to be adequate citizens
of this very interlocking
and complicated world.
The first is the Socratic one,
the ability to examine your own beliefs
and just ask what are your reasons
for believing what you believe?
And I want to say that that's essential
for a reasoned public culture,
for a culture where it's not
just sound bytes on talk radio,
but it's really serious
deliberation and reasoned debate.
Then learning about other countries.
So the whole part with,
I call the citizen of the world part
means a lot more knowledge
than people used to get
than what I got about
non-western cultures.
I want to include in that the knowledge
of at least one foreign language
because I think even if it's,
let's say French or Italian,
you still learn something
from that about how
another group of people sees the world
and how difficult it is to translate that
so neatly into your own language.
But I also think you need
to learn about minorities
in your own country.
So I devote some time to women studies,
African-American studies,
studies of human sexuality.
Then the third one which
goes closely with the second
is the cultivation of the imagination.
Now, I think it's not enough,
although you have to do it,
to learn historical facts
and facts about economics,
but you need to be able to
think what it might be like
to be in a position
different from your own,
so that the arts, not just literature,
but also drama, also dance, music,
these have a big role to play
in cultivating the sort of person
who's prepared to go out into the world
and think well about these problems.
Now, I did this for higher education
simply because that was what I knew
and there were all these debates
raging at the time about it
but now I feel I want
to return to it again
and write something
about earlier education
because I feel that these things
are increasingly in
jeopardy all over the world,
the things I care about because
people are so eager for
success in the global market
that they want kids to learn
what will enrich the nation.
And everyone is talking about
technology education now
and science education.
I don't think these are bad things,
but I think they're just not sufficient.
And certainly in India,
it's gone very, very far,
so parents will, their glory will be
if their child gets into
the Indian Institute of
Technology and Management.
They'll be ashamed to have
a child who's an artist
or a writer or a humanist.
And that part, even the
critical thinking part
is sorely lacking because
kids are being stuffed
with all the things they
need to pass these exams
and not taught to think for themselves.
I think in the US, this is happening.
I mean, when we hear all kinds
of people in our leadership
talking about education,
and certainly preparing reports about it.
it's all about science and technology,
nothing about humanities and arts.
So I'm getting more and more into this,
and the Association of American
colleges and Universities
has produced a very good report
that I've been kind of advising on
about the complex set of skills
that kids really do
need, and then of course,
they're focused on higher education too,
but it has to begin
earlier if people are to be
adequate citizens by the
time they get to college.
So this is an important thing to harp on
and I'm getting more and more worried
that we're gonna have
nations of docile engineers
who won't know how to examine the claims
of a political leader.
In India, the state that
has particularly gone down
this road is the state of Gujarat
where kids for generations now
have not learned much critical thinking,
and they're stuffed
with this rote learning,
and that is the state that's had
the largest amount of religious violence,
there's no public criticism,
or not enough in the state
that is of the leadership,
although plenty of criticism from outside
and national media.
But I think the education
system is part of the problem,
that people have to learn to be critical
and to do it respectfully and publicly.
And only then will we have
the kind of journalism,
the kind of political
culture that we really need.
- One final question.
You have assumed a role
as a public intellectual,
and one has to comment on
the poor state of that
role in our country today,
which then affects our public
debate on global issues,
it affects our debate
on education and so on.
You're unique in the
sense that you still bring
the thoughtful reasoning
that you employ in your field.
Talk a little about that.
What can we do about
that public discourse?
Is it training people more in
philosophical ways of thinking
and introducing a program
like you've just described?
What can make the difference
so we elevate the discourse?
- I think it's very, very
difficult in this country.
I think the first thing
we ought to notice is
that we're pretty isolated in this regard.
I've just come back from
Holland, and in Holland,
philosophy is big news
in the popular culture.
There's a popular magazine, Philosophie,
that presents accounts of
issues for the general public.
It's not a gossip column magazine.
And if you give a lecture,
I mean, I gave the Dutch
translation of one of my books,
and of course the very fact
that a book of philosophy
would be translated into Dutch
when anyone who is an
academic reads English
is itself quite interesting.
Well, people are all
coming to these lectures,
they want to know about
the philosophical issues.
So my belief is that human
beings are not that different
from one country to the other.
Issues about grief and warning,
issues about social justice,
these are issues that
people really care about.
And in America, they
just don't get the access
to discussion about these issues
because the media have decided
that that just isn't interesting.
Now, why is that?
Now I think part of it is the
increasing corporate control
of the media.
The fact is that even when
they want to do something more
in the public interest,
and CBS is owned by Viacom,
et cetera, et cetera,
so you get all of this top-down control
which produces focus on short-term profit,
and therefore on sensationalism.
I think major national newspapers
have certainly gotten worse.
I think The New York Times Book Review
and The New York Times op-ed page
have gotten measurably worse
in the last couple of years.
The Post is much better,
but that's always been America-focused,
so it's not one of my main venues,
so I find that it's through
the Book Review only
that you can get out
to the general public.
And even there, I mean, the New Republic,
which has a brilliant literary editor,
he has fewer pages now
because of financial issues
than he had before.
So where can one get
access to this public?
I think if young people thought
that there was a way that
they could get their thoughts
about issues into print,
I mean, my graduate students
would work much more on that,
but since it's so hard, then they have,
almost an incentive not to do it
because it also jeopardizes
their career in philosophy.
I'm the chair of the
Committee on Public Philosophy
in the American Philosophical Association
and I know that there's tremendous
passion for these things
and there are a lot of good efforts
at the community level going
on that we don't hear about.
There are a lot of philosophy
cafes, public discussions,
local newspapers, local TV.
And then of course there
are people like you
who do things that have a larger audience,
and I would mention the
show Philosophy Talk
that John Perry and Ken
Taylor do out of Stanford.
I think that's a wonderful program.
And so there are rays of hope,
but it is so much easier
for me to talk to the press
in India, in Holland, in Italy, in Germany
than it is in my own country,
and I think that's pretty weird.
And I mean, we are a nation
that has always had
suspicion of intellectuals,
and that's part of it,
but I think the media are to blame.
- Well on that note, we
hope that more people
will read what you have written,
and we hope to have you back at Berkeley
to give another lecture.
And at that time, we'll
do another interview
and can talk about another
dimension of your work.
Thank you very much.
- I will.
- Thank you very much.
- And thank you very much for joining us
for this Conversation with History.
(dramatic music)